kind enough to put on a headset here
after the game and
join us is uh rajon rondo
so let's go down to the bubble in
orlando what do you say
there you go rajon thank you thank you
so much congratulations on
on winning game one here um your team is
now five and one since you've come back
and played with them what exactly is it
that you try to take to the floor every
night
um just poison confidence you know being
installed on my roll taking care of the
ball and leading by example as a point
guard on the floor with my unit
rondo shack here we know lebron loves
the ball at all times
what did it take uh you know what did it
take you to convince him to say lebron
let me control the game you know know
what i'm saying you just played beside
me
what was that conversation like it
wasn't much as a conversation it's just
obviously just getting to know each
other you know understanding that you
know he brought me here for a reason
and i'm here to make his job a lot
easier and as long as they allow me to
do that
you know things have been uh been
running pretty smoothly and that he uh
he's able to trust me rondo
draymond man you're playing really well
uh you and ad have an amazing connection
what do y'all see with the denver
defense it's where you're able to get
those over the top lives and
a lot of stuff for a.d at the rim oh i
can't give you too much right now
draymond they're watching but
um you know we've been playing together
for a couple years now and um you know i
go back and try to break down him as
much as possible
i'm always winning the wreakside help
and it's only one person to go get those
balls i throw up and in the air so
as long as it's a smaller guard on the
opposite side i always try to throw it
as high as i can and
uh he goes and does the rest you know
rondo there's a
there's a couple of different lakers
that we see we see you know the half
court
we see the the um energy and pushing it
up
your role would you say is the more
increase the tempo
keep the tempo or stop
the other teachers temple it just
depends on part what part of the game
you know each game is different but for
the most part
night after night i'm usually trying to
push the pace you know um we're a fast
breaking team when we want to be
we try to make emphasis on attacking the
paint um they don't have many or any
great shot blockers so
tonight it was just trying to attack the
paint and get to the free-throw line
which you did in the first half
and uh put the put the balls on the
rap's hand you know
i've been looking at a bunch of stuff
from down in the bubble
some guys are playing golf some guys are
fishing
are you involved in any of those
activities
no activities at all just taking care of
my body uh you know things are going
fast we're playing every other day now
it's not like the usual playoffs so
me personally my brother's here i'm able
to you know kind of relax with him we go
to breakfast and lunch pretty much and
dinner pretty much every other day
and i'll try to take her my body stay
focused and continue to work on
different game plans for each game
we just finished showing the highlights
and the last shot
we showed was was your shot around the
along the baseline and from behind
the backboard take me through that uh
just trying to get around that side of
plumley and i knew at the angle i would
have it i would have to use
you know high arc on the ball a little
bit of touch i think it might be my
first float all playoffs so
i felt good to go in obviously uh we're
up with a big lead and i try to get the
ball above the back board and make a
play
you know rondo you've been on you know
championship teams and now
you're in the western conference final
what is the ingredient
that you see in both teams that you've
been on that won championships
came close and on that that you're in
now unselfishness
you know we're able to play for each
other um guys are rooting for one
another regardless if we're in the same
position you know
a great example is myself and alex
crusoe you know when he's on the court
i'm wishing him well and vice versa so
this is a great
uh great team camaraderie we're all
willing to sacrifice and
and obviously give our coaching staff a
great great credit as well
in these playoffs you've passed isaiah
thomas and dennis johnson
tonight michael jordan on the playoff
assist list yeah it brings a little
smile to your face
man mention my name with isaiah and mike
you know it's definitely a humbling uh
humbling experience and feeling so i'm
going to soak it all in the night get
back and watch film and
you know obviously that's the teammate
award so i can't thank my teammates
enough you know those guys make the
shots and
they're allowing me to push the ball and
trust me with the ball and like i said
they're making the shot so
it's a team effort i want to do it
without all of my teammates i play with
and i'm very fortunate
and uh thankful to have those
opportunities to play with certain guys
in this league
we appreciate you stopping by go watch
some film no golf no
no fishing tomorrow appreciate it
how do you how do you assess what you
see from the lakers and from a guy who
faces them on a regular basis
tell me about the defense the lakers
play i think their defense was
tremendous tonight especially in the
second half
uh you know guys are really stepping up
to the challenge kcp is stepping up to
the challenge with um
with jamal murray and dwight was
fantastic on joker and so was a.d
they're really taking the pain away
they're making it tough for for the
nuggets to get things
going in the paint and when you gotta
operate your offense everything from
outside
it gets tough you never get a chance to
get in the rhythm you're denver where do
you go from here
well denver is right where they want to
be uh you know
we all know we've seen it they're not
going to quit they're not going to panic
they're not going to even get down on
themselves they're saying to themselves
okay the lakers had their way you guys
were arrested we're coming off with
multiple
we were in foul trouble the first half
we know we got to do we turned the ball
over too many times we can play we can
compete
they're not gonna give up you're gonna
have to you know really really put this
team away
down one game down two games we know
what they did the question is
will their luck run out can they
continue to do it yeah the question it's
one thing to know what you need to do
that's another thing to accomplish that
in this series kenny yeah i mean
ernie game one after a seven game series
just from experience
that's a difficult game for a team who
played a seven-game series especially
coming out of a win because the emotion
that you had to build up for that one
night
not saying that certain things they're
going to have to adjust but emotionally
they it's difficult to be there and um
you know they're a young team they
weren't there emotionally tonight
so i i said this was like a throwaway
game for them
they have now game two this is we're
going to see
if if the things that they think are
going to work against the lakers going
to work
and the things they think they can stop
against the lakers i think the
two or three things that they would have
to pay attention to is rondo
and howard those guys can't have big
moments
not not games big moments in the key
moments of those games when they were up
eight
they made a three-point play or
three-point pass or out and one
a blocked shot they can't have them in
the moment of the game those guys can
get 12 points 10 points
but they can't have the key moments if
you're going to have jokic
and murray play the way they did today
listen it's just a bad matchup
playoffs are all about matchups like the
milwaukee bucks
if they ever played any other team in
the east they probably would have made
it to the conference finals but that was
a bad matchup with them with the miami
heat
this is the clippers as talents they are
we said i said this earlier we said the
key to the lakers and clipper series
when they play
can although davis killed all those
little guys that the clippers got
joker killed all those little guys the
clippers got
he can't kill dwight howard and anthony
davis
and he can't guard them on the other end
that's not gonna change
by sunday night he can't guard anthony
davis
and he can't keep the white howard off
the boards and lebron gonna do his thing
so it's just a bad matchup for the
clippers like i say they've had a great
season
but it's all about match-ups
anthony davis goes for 37-10 lebron does
not score in the second half
but the lakers lead by 27 and cruised by
12 to take a one-nothing lead in that
series